Donald Trump uh issued a Christmas
message that was not heartwarming in
fact it was a scary meltdown in which he
is obviously terrified terrified
terrified of getting himself indicted
here is Donald Trump's post to Troth
Central
on Christmas and it is not exactly
a message riddled with the imagery we
might expect of reindeer and
um gingerbread I don't know what people
do on Christmas exactly you know I do
Jewish Christmas which is I get Indian
food or Chinese food and that's exactly
what I did but it doesn't seem this is
the Christmas imagery Trump said quote
Merry Christmas to everyone including
the radical left marxists of which there
are almost none that are trying to
destroy our Capital C country
the Federal Bureau of Investigation that
is illegally coercing and paying social
and lame stream media to push for a
mentally disabled Democrat over the
capital B brilliant Capital C
Clairvoyant Trump calling himself
Clairvoyant and USA loving Donald J
Trump
and of course the department of
Injustice which appointed a special
quote prosecutor end quote who together
with his wife and family hates quote
Trump end quote more than any other
person on Earth
love to all Trump says in all caps Obama
this is a man
deathly terrified
of getting indicted now later in the
show we're going to talk about the
suggestion that Trump would be best
served pleading Insanity at a
forthcoming trial hypothetical
forthcoming trial and again even if
there are charges it doesn't mean
there's going to be a trial
um this is a guy who's very very scared
and of course we all know if and when
Trump is indicted he's going to say it's
politically biased and it's bogus and
it's nonsense and it's the radical left
marxists and all these different things
and why didn't they invite Obama indict
Obama why didn't they indict George H.W
bush for uh putting his uh documents in
a Chinese Laundry slash restaurant which
he didn't do and what about Obama's sock
draw as he likes to say he means drawer
um we know that's what he's going to say
but we know that he's genuinely
terrified of that indictment and even if
he thinks that jail time prison time is
unlikely as I do I think it is not going
to happen just it's not going to happen
even though Jaime Raskin now is saying
Trump will end up behind bars we'll talk
about that tomorrow I don't think it's
going to happen
Trump is scared and he doesn't want to
be indicted and he is likely being
advised by lawyers based on the reports
we have about their strategizing that he
is going to get indicted maybe by the
southern district of New York maybe by
the doj federally maybe in Georgia maybe
in all three maybe in two of the three
um and he's terrified and he's coming
unglued and that's exactly what we are
seeing we are going to later in the week
dig into some of the other aspects of
this but later on in today's show we
will talk about Insanity defenses in
general which is actually a really
interesting topic and Lawrence tribe's
recent explanation of why that's Trump's
best bet we will take a quick break make
sure you have liked the show on
Facebook's
Zuckerberg's Facebooks at facebook.com
slash David Pacman show as many of you
know I am fascinated by cons and scams
and multi-level marketing and all of
this different stuff I recently saw
Inside the Mind of a con artist on
curiosity stream it's six episodes and
it was excellent I don't think I would
have discovered it were it not for our
sponsor curiosity stream curiosity
stream has all the newest and best
documentary films they've got the big
titles from the well-known filmmakers
they've got valuable Independent films
tons of original content that you can't
find anywhere else when I'm at home
browsing my different streaming
platforms I find curiosity stream to
really have the best selection of
documentaries specifically because
documentaries is all that they have and
they're always adding new titles my
audience gets access to curiosity
streams entire library of documentaries
for just 15 bucks a year that's 25 off
go to a curiositystream.com pacman or
use the code Pacman the link is down
below